[Musik]
die russische invasion in der ukraine
das iranische nuklearprogramm die
nordkoreanische atombombe und der
chinesische expansionismus im
südchinesischen meer die welt steht in
flammen und der mittelpunkt der
internationalen politik stehen nun nicht
mehr handeln und ernährung sondern
vielmehr spaltung und die
auseinandersetzung mit militärischen
mitteln wie wladimir putins aggression
gegen die ukraine hat ein gewaltiges
politisches erdbeben ausgelöst niemand
traut mehr jenen nachbarn die einen nur
selten größen stattdessen jedoch dauernd
darum müssen sich ins trennte
angelegenheiten einmischen und sich auch
des öfteren uneingeladen im eigenen
vorgarten breit machen der vom kreml
ausgelöste alptraum hat uns alle daran
erinnert dass das für viele bisher
unvorstellbare jederzeit möglich ist und
angesichts dieser neuen welt lage es
sich durchaus lohnt vorsichtig zu sein
wir sehen es in europa wo praktisch alle
länder für die kommenden jahre
rekordinvestitionen im militärbereich
ankündigen von den kleinsten nationen
wie estland bis hin zu den größten weg
deutschland und genau diesen trend
können wir auch in der
asiatisch-pazifischen region besonders
deutlich sehen
ich denke man kann mit fug und recht
behaupten dass chinas beziehungen zu den
meisten seiner nachbarin in letzter zeit
nicht gerade prickelnd sind china ist
auf dem weg zur supermacht und die
regierung verschiebe hat beschlossen
dass es deswegen nicht mehr darauf
angewiesen ist allzu große rücksicht auf
andere nehmen zu müssen sie zeigt immer
mehr ihr wahres gesicht aber inwieweit
können sich seine nachbarn auf ein land
mit china verlassen was tun sie um vom
roten riesen nicht platt gewalzt zu
werben nun zum glück sind sie schon
etwas früher erwartet als europa wo man
nachrichten wie die folgende weitgehend
ignorierte oder gar kritisierte die
ausgaben steigen 2021 um 2,8 prozent
entgegen einem weltweiten rückgang um
1,8 prozent das wachstum in der region
verlangsame sich aber die ausgaben
halten den wirtschaftlichen druck stand
und natürlich hat jetzt nach putins
überfall auf die ukraine auch japan den
schlag gehört aber was bedeutet das
konkret über die erhöhung der
militärhaushalt hinaus die er nun in
europa einzug hält nun passt gut auf
denn an dieser stelle müssen wir etwas
ganz besonderes beachten ja china ist
zur regionalen großmacht im asiatisch
pazifischen raum geworden aber ihr
einfluss ist nicht zu überwältigen die
man auf den ersten blick becken könnte
die chinesische marine ist zum beispiel
die größte und mächtigste stellt aber
nur etwa 30 prozent der tonnage in der
region dar mit anderen worten der
wettbewerb dort ist verdammt dieses mal
wollen wir uns aber nicht die großen
player wie japan südkorea australien
teil waren oder china selbst ansehen
sondern zwei neue sehr schnell
aufstrebende militärmächte im asiatisch
pazifischen raum weil ich vielleicht
noch weit von der ersten liga entfernt
sind deren situation sich aber im laufe
weniger jahre radikal ändern könnte und
aufgepasst denn diese länder wachsen
nicht nur wirtschaftlich sehr schnell
nein ihre fertilitätsrate sind auch noch
wesentlich gesünder als die chinas und
südkoreas ihnen gehört die demografische
zukunft in dieser gewaltigen
wirtschaftsregierung heute schon
verfügen sie über eine bevölkerungszahl
von 370 millionen menschen welche jedoch
in zukunft vielleicht 400 millionen
überschreiten kann und dann mit der
chinesischen küstenregionen vergleichbar
ist nur mit dem unterschied dass sie
noch von jugend stoßen werden während in
china eine überalterte bevölkerung vor
sich hin schrumpfen wird also wer genau
sind diese länder die dazu bestimmt sind
im nächsten militär nicht in der region
zu werben und wie einflussreichen sie
eigentlich können sie jene zünglein an
der waage sein die das zukünftige macht
gleichgewicht zwischen china und dem
westen entscheiden nun lasst uns sofort
loslegen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
darf mal einen blick auf diese karte
was ihr seht ist das südchinesische meer
mit den wichtigsten territorialen
ansprüchen der anrainerländer die leicht
zu erkennen ist handelt es sich um eine
ziemlich vertrackte situation da streit
um diese gewässer ist so irrsinnig dass
bis zu vier länder genau zur gleichen
zeit dasselbe stück vom kuchen
beanspruchen und das hauptproblem ist
dass china immer weniger bereit zu sein
scheint sich mit dem ganzen schlamassel
konstruktiv auseinander zu setzen
immerhin ist ist das größte und stärkste
land in der region warum also nicht
einfach seinen willen brachial
durchsetzen warum nicht das ganze gebiet
übernehmen das die für ihr eigentum
halten und alle natürlichen ressourcen
kontrollieren die in diesen gewässern
liegen könnten und wisst ihr was genau
dieser gedankengang scheint sich schon
seit einiger zeit entschieden drinks
kopf abzuspielen genau deshalb
verschärfte chinesische regierung zu
nehmen denn ton und ihre forderungen
bezüglich dieser gebietsansprüche aber
natürlich wissen chinas nachbarn nicht
untätig herum und sie haben sich gesagt
wir sollten lieber auf der hut sein
aber die so genannte volksrepublik china
will die führung übernehmen endlich
wieder das reich der mitte seien eine
uneingeschränkte hegemonialmacht werden
die auf keinen rücksicht nehmen muss und
wenn man die chinesischen medien
beobachtet scheint dieser
minderwertigkeitskomplex den chinesen
gewaltig unter den fingern zu trennen
denn angesichts des nahenden
demografischen niedergangs scheint dies
die letzte chance zu sein bei den
nationalisten herrscht torschlusspanik
wenn nicht jetzt wann dann ihr problem
ist nur dass die nachbarn nicht bereits
sind die größenwahnsinnigen zipperlein
die chinesen zu befriedigen
denn nur weil china das stärkste land
ist müssen sie noch lange nicht
akzeptieren das ist eine dominierende
macht wird während also china seinen
militärhaushalt zwischen 2003 und 2008
10 um 620 prozent erhöht hat vietnam
seien um rund 690 prozent erhöht und
andere länder wie indonesien oder
thailand die ihren haushalt um 250 bzw
264 prozent aufgestockt haben wollen
jetzt noch mehr aufs gaspedal treten
sagen wir einfach dass angesichts der
militärischen eskalation chinas immer
mehr länder in der region zu demselben
schluss gekommen sind wenn wir uns nicht
vorbereiten könnte das für uns
katastrophal enden ein gedanke der sich
bei der aktuellen russische invasion in
der ukraine wieder als übertreibung noch
als unbegründete angst erwiesen hat
[Applaus]
china hatte auf usa mehr als drei inseln
im südchinesischen meer vollständig
militarisiert vietnam baut militärische
stärke auf um china zu kontern die usa
verstärkung ihrer militärischen
beziehungen in südostasien und china zu
bekämpfen hättet ihr euch zum beispiel
vorstellen können dass zum beispiel
vietnam der neue aufsteigen des stars
südost asiens seinen militärhaushalt
noch schneller und stärker erhöht als
china selbst und hat es nicht schon
allein deswegen ein eigenes visual
politik video verdient nun nicht nur das
unserer ansicht nach hat es mindestens
drei verdient und dies hier ist der
erste teil unserer vietnam trilogie in
den weiteren folgen werden wir uns
zuerst auf die geschichtlichen
hintergründe der chinesischen rivalität
konzentrieren und dann auf die äußerst
spannenden wirtschaftlichen aspekte und
perspektiven die sich aus dieser ganzen
entwicklung ergeben vergesst also bitte
nicht das abo und natürlich das
benachrichtigungs glöckchen um keines
dieser videos zu verpassen vietnam ist
ja der große diversifizierung gewinner
der chinesischen zero cockpit und
lockten politik und einige zuschauer
haben uns in den kommentaren gefragt was
wir von der theorie halten die jetzigen
lockt aus und china wären verdeckte
sanktionen gegen den westen nun dieses
motiv ist allein schon deswegen sehr
unwahrscheinlich weil peking sich an
einer hand abzählen kann dass solche
sanktionen zum genauen gegenteil dessen
führen würden was sie eigentlich
bezwecken soll denn es würde damit
langfristig nur seine wirtschaftlichen
rivalen die eben vietnam oder auch
osteuropa stärken und den großen
investment rente substitution
chinesischer produktion durch andere
schwellenländer nur noch beschleunigen
wie wir in unserem vorletzten video
erläutert haben kann sich china so was
allein aus demografischen gründen nicht
leisten und wenn man sich ansieht welche
regierung und branchen am stärksten von
den loks betroffen sind wird relativ
klar dass es jemand bevorzugt
innenpolitischer machtkämpfe unter
anderem zwischen der shi und der gesang
fraktion handelt wir haben über diese
schon in einigen früheren videos
gesprochen zb in bezug auf das bankwesen
alibaba das great barrier die agenda des
gemeinsamen wohlstand vor kurzem im
olympia video noch blöder klingt
freilich die theorie china wolle mit den
half erschließungen im rahmen der
angeblichen verdeckten sanktionen
russland helfen denn 80 prozent der
chinesischen exporte für russland werden
über den seeweg abgewickelt aber zurück
nachdem den wollen wir uns ja aufs
militär konzentrieren also aufgepasst
[Musik]
geschichte die sich nicht wiederholen
wird
vietnam weiß nur zu gut was es heißt
einer fremden macht gegenüber zu stehen
im zwanzigsten jahrhundert captain die
vietnamesen gegen frankreich die usa und
ja auch schon gegen china selbst aber
wie gesagt über diese geschichte
erzählen wir euch in einem eigenen video
eines dürfte jedoch klar sein wenn die
vietnamesen etwas gelernt haben dann
dass sie auf alle eventualitäten
vorbereitet sein müssen
[Musik]
aus diesem grund hat die chinesische
regierung die massive aufrüstung als
eine der grundlegendsten achsen ihrer
berühmten im jahr 1986 beschlossenen
agenda aufgenommen um ihr
wirtschaftssystem zu reformieren und
schrittweise ein stars kapitalistisches
und teilweise auch marktwirtschaftliche
modell nach chinesischem vorbild
einzuführen heißt übersetzt erneuerung
oder innovation zu den zielen gehörte
auch eine militärreform denn bis dahin
glichen die vietnamesischen streitkräfte
eher eine ansammlung zersplitterter
schlecht ausgerüstet und schlecht
ausgebildete militärischen grüppchen die
idee nicht miteinander zu tun hatten
der zusammenbruch der sowjetunion brest
diese reform zunächst aus vietnam war
ein sehr armes land und der
zusammenbruch der sowjetunion von der es
wirtschaftlich abhängig war macht die
lage nur noch schlimmer die
modernisierung des militärs musste also
erstmal warten doch mit dem beginn des
neuen jahrtausends und der öffnung
gegenüber der welt lebte die
vietnamesische wirtschaft eine gewaltige
revolution und wurde zu einer der am
schnellsten wachsenden volkswirtschaften
der welt bereits 2006 setzte sich der
zehnte national kongress der
kommunistischen partei vietnams das ziel
das land zu einer vollwertigen seemacht
zu machen sowohl wirtschaftlich und
handelns technisch als auch militärisch
[Musik]
vietnam hat daher begonnen sich mit
relativ modernen waffen auszurüsten die
hauptsächlich aus russland stammen aber
auch südkoreanische fregatte zur
u-boot-abwehr französische hubschrauber
und israelische drohnen gehören zum
inventar ganz zu schweigen von einer
immer größer werdende menge an gutes
ausrüstung denn koste ihrer geschichte
haben sich die beziehungen zwischen den
usa und vietnam in den letzten jahren
immer mehr verbessert
ja vietnam ist viel ärmer als china und
sein militär etat beträgt immer noch nur
einen bruchteil von dem seines
nördlichen nachbarn aber wenn die
ukraine eines bewiesen hat dann dass man
nicht unbedingt der stärkste sein muss
wenn man über bestimmte
kriegsentscheidende fähigkeiten verfügt
und vor allem über gute und mächtige
freunde
japan und vietnam unterzeichnen ein
abkommen über den transfer von
rüstungsgütern inmitten der sorgen um
china wo es gibt tendenzen kamera harris
auf historischen besuch in vietnam und
eines wissen sie alle im vietnamkrieg
hat das land bereits bewiesen was für
eine falle es für eine ausländische
macht sein kann aloys strategie besteht
also darin china die kosten für den
versuch die genetischen inseln im
südchinesischen meer zu übernehmen so
hoch wie möglich zu machen das erklärt
zb die entschlossenheit ihre u boot
flotte zu einem der stärksten
strategischen elemente ihre verteidigung
zu machen ihr plan hält derzeit sechs
boote einsatzbereit und investiert
beträchtliche ressourcen in die
verstärkung der verteidigung des bradley
inselgruppe wo es über raketenwerfer und
angriffs systeme mit ausreichender
reichweite verfügt um die von china
kontrollierten inseln anzugreifen und
ihre flugplätze und radarsysteme zu
neutralisieren
dabei handelt es sich nicht nur um eine
politische oder territoriale frage soll
vor allem eine ökonomische vietnam
erlebt einen enormen wirtschaftlichen
aufschwung und immer mehr unternehmen
sehen das land als möglich alternative
zu china oder zumindest als möglichkeit
ihre abhängigkeit vom asiatischen riesen
zu verringern es ist also nicht
ungewöhnlich auf nachrichten wie diese
so stoßen samstag investierten 920
millionen dollar in den ausbau des werks
in vietnam apple zulieferer foxconn baut
270 millionen dollar teures werk in
vietnam inmitten der spannungen zwischen
den usa und china lg display erhöht
investition in vietnamesisches werk um
1,4 milliarden dollar die lego gruppe
kündigt pläne zum bau einer neuen fabrik
in vietnam an um das langfristige
wachstum zu unterstützen
genau aus diesem grund ist die kontrolle
und gewährleistung der sicherheit und
integrität der gewässer durch die
vietnam all diese waren exportiert von
grundlegender bedeutung wir sind wieder
in einer welt in der nur militärische
sicherheit investitionssicherheit
garantiert und so können weiterhin
ausländische direktinvestitionen
angezogen werden denn wir haben es in
vielen früheren videos immer wieder
betont wir haben es hier mit jener
region zu tun welche den zukünftigen und
am schnellsten wachsenden motor der
weltwirtschaft darstellt und es gibt im
moment kein größeres einzelnes faust
fand mit dem man die weltwirtschaft
kontrollieren kann als die see dieser
region und die damit verbundenen
handelswege meine lieben des wahl-
politik- fans das wettrennen um genau
dieses faustpfand ist in vollem gange
und vietnam ist bei weitem nicht das
einzige land das sich in bewegung setzt
um ist nicht den machthabern in peking
zu überlassen
[Musik]
von der ukraine lernen heißt siegen
lernen
[Musik]
wenn es ein land in südostasien gibt das
danach strebt ein wichtiger akteur in
der region zu werden dann ist es kein
anderes als indonesien die gründe dafür
nur die gleichen die wir bereits im fall
von vietnam gesehen haben die bedrohung
durch china und die notwendigkeit die
kontrolle über die gewässer zu
gewährleisten durch welche die
wachsenden export des landes in den rest
der welt ließen es geht jedoch nicht nur
um die eigenen zugegebenermaßen
gewaltigen ambitionen tatsache ist dass
jakarta genug von den ständigen
chinesischen militär interventionen in
seinen gewässern hat das erklärt warum
sie endlich ein machtwort sprechen
wollten und zumindest in den medien
konnten sich damit etwas aufmerksamkeit
gewinnen indonesiens 125 milliarden
dollar für luft- und seestreitkräfte
könnten in den nächsten zwei jahren 50
kriegsschiffe auf sie bedeuten
angesichts der übergriffe chinas auf die
erweiterte verschluss von indonesiens
strebt verteidigungsminister proviant
oder eine größere investition in
militärischen rüstung an nun ja diese
nachricht gilt reißerische als das was
sich dahinter wirklich verbirgt da es
sich um eine langfristige investition
behandelt aber diese art von
ankündigungen sind eine möglichkeit zu
sagen hey wir sind gekommen um zu
bleiben und den nächsten jahren werden
wir das thema militär viel ernster
nehmen als bisher
denn bis jetzt wurden militärische
angelegenheiten in indonesien den
meisten ländern der region er als
zweitrangig eingestuft und tatsächlich
ist das indonesische militär nicht nur
extrem veraltet sondern zu einem großen
teil auch in einem sehr schlechten
zustand
zum beispiel seien im juli 2020 ein
landungsschiff aus den siebziger jahren
dass indonesien von der ddr erworben
hatte im jahr 2021 verloren sie 1 40
jahre altes boot bei torpedo übungen
wobei 43 matrosen ums leben kamen
darüber hinaus sind unfälle mit
ausbildungs flugzeugen und leichten
kampfflugzeugen an der tagesordnung
die material ist in den nächsten jahren
ein treffen könnte gehören top
rüstungsgüter wie die französische
rafale die neuesten versionen der us
amerikanischen f 15 und das
nordkoreanische kampfflugzeuge f 21 an
wissen entwicklungsprogramm indonesien
sogar beteiligt ist vor allem aber hat
die militär strategie des landes die
entwicklung eines sogenannten
greenwashing zur priorität ein begriff
der sich auf seestreitkräfte bezieht die
auf die verteidigung von küsten
spezialisiert sind dies würde es den
insel staat einerseits ermöglichen das
nationale territorium zu kontrollieren
vergesst nicht dass wir über ein land
aus mehr als 17.000 inseln sprechen und
andererseits jegliche ambitionen chinas
auf die umstrittenen inseln zum blocken
die idee ist ein bisschen wie das was
wir in der ukraine gesehen haben eine
viel stärkere macht wird es sich zweimal
überlegen bevor sie es wagt in ein
solches wissen lässt zu stechen
diese strategie nennt man operative
psychologische abschreckung im fall
indonesiens besteht ihre implementation
im aufbau eines die verteidigung die
jeden feindliche übergriffe so teuer
macht dass der potentielle angreifer
seine pläne komplett aufgibt mit anderen
worten dass sich das
kosten-nutzen-verhältnis führt ihnen
nicht auszahlt
um besser zu verstehen was konkret
dahinter steckt können wir zum beispiel
einen blick auf die natur inseln werfen
dies sind 272 inseln die sich unter
indonesischer kontrolle befinden jedoch
innerhalb der von china beanspruchten
linie liegen und diese inseln haben es
in sich es wird geschätzt dass ihren
untergrund billionen von guti metern
erdgas beherbergt tatsächlich konnte die
enorme menge an gas die dort vermutet
wird sie zu einem der größten gasfelder
welt machen und ich wiederhole china
beansprucht diese bisher indonesischen
inseln als ein exklusives eigentum ich
bin ziemlich sicher dass er es besser
versteht warum indonesien entschlossen
lässt diese grüne wasser armada so
schnell wie möglich auf die beine zu
stellen bzw
zu wasser zu lassen geplant ist die
beschaffung von sage und schreibe
274 schiffen zehnkampf luke gespann und
12 9 diesen boten sowie einer riesigen
menge weiterer rüstungsgüter indonesien
will u boot flotte nach chinesischen
übergriffen verdreifachen natürlich gibt
es dabei auch ein problem viele experten
weisen darauf hin dass präzisions
gelenkte raketen und drohnen ist peking
ermöglichen würden das gebiet von der
ferne anzugreifen und sturmreif zu
schießen noch bevor er seine flugzeuge
schiffe und truppen überhaupt in die
ausschließliche wirtschaftszone
indonesiens eindringen würden das wäre
das sogenannte krieg von zu hause aus
aber auch hierfür will man sich in
jakarta rüsten und ihr wisst ganz genau
wissen know-how man dafür braucht das
gleiche wie in der ukraine das von
andris m denn wenn der krieg in der
ukraine etwas gezeigt hat dann war es
vor allem dass die überlebensfähigkeit
eines kleineren staates in der
hegemonialen eines großen imperiums nur
durch zwei dinge gewährleistet werden
kann die eigene resilienz und sehr viel
hilfe aus dem pentagon vietnam und
indonesien sind sich dessen so bewusst
wie nie zuvor sie sind zwei beispiele
für aufstrebende volkswirtschaften die
jetzt anfangen dieses thema wirklich
ernst zu nehmen zusammen bald mehr als
400 millionen einwohner haben werden und
sich wirtschaftlich immer weiter
entwickeln mit anderen worten wir reden
hier über alles andere als ein
unerhebliches potenzial doch bevor wir
zu ende kommen möchte ich euch eine
schöne karte nicht vorenthalten schaut
euch mal folgendes an
erinnert ihr euch daran was vorhin über
die tonale der seestadt kräfte in der
region gesagt haben china entwickelt
sich zu einer supermacht aber es ist
eine umzingelte macht die nur schwer
eine vormachtstellung erreichen wird
wenn wir südkorea japan die philippinen
taiwan vietnam und indonesien betrachten
sehen wir wie sie zusammen eine art
gewaltige sicherheitsbarriere bilden die
chinas an beziehungen stark einschränkt
und dazu zwingt an sehr vielen
verschiedenen fronten gleichzeitig
aufpassen zu müssen alle zu vielen
fronten um einen mächtigen schlag seine
konzentrierte streitkräfte erfolgreich
ausführen zu können damit befindet es
sich bereits jetzt in einer ähnlichen
situation wie russland das einen großen
teil seiner truppen an seinen endlosen
außengrenzen sowie im inland gebunden
halten muss um nicht von allen seiten ob
von georgien aserbaidschan oder durch
inländische separatisten angegriffen zu
werden sobald es irgendwo eine schwäche
bietet auch chinas militär wird also auf
diese art in einer verzettelung
strategie zahnlos gehalten deshalb sind
die verbesserung der militärischen
fähigkeiten der schlagkraft und
verteidigungsbereitschaft vietnams
indonesiens oder der philippinen
geopolitisch von unschätzbarem wert vor
allem wenn diese länder engere
beziehungen zu den usa südkorea und
japan knüpfen so wie es zurzeit in immer
größerem ausmaß der fall ist schließlich
ist das aggressive auftreten chinas und
russlands selbst welche sie immer weiter
in die arme usa treiben doch das spiel
ist noch lange nicht vorbei der krieg in
der ukraine hat in all diesen ländern
große ängste geweckt sie tun und alles
damit sie nicht zu einer künftigen
ukraine werden denn sanktionen hin oder
her wenn eines klar geworden ist dann
dass wir uns wieder in einer ära
befinden in der militärische und
wirtschaftliche stärke direkt
miteinander verbunden sind und dass eine
mit hilfe des anderen durchgesetzt wird
aber ihr seid ihr erst mal an der reihe
welche länder werden eurer meinung nach
die zukünftigen militärmächte der welt
sein wie weit wird chinas macht reichen
und kann es überhaupt eine dominierende
macht in der asiatisch-pazifischen
region werden wie weit wird dieser
militärische wettlauf gehen die immer
sind wir auf eure beiträge und
diskussionen zu diesem thema schon sehr
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
video gefallen hat was ja geht uns mit
einem like 1000 freunde und vergesst
nicht dass man mit glücklich und keines
unserer teams messen verpassen natürlich
freuen wir uns auch jederzeit über eine
spende von euch mit dem uns hält diese
projekte weiterzuführen denn paper link
dazu findet ihr beschreibung unter dem
video mach's gut und bis bald
[Musik]